hi I'm Dorian Rudolph and I present the
talk Quantum space ground space
traversal and how to embed multi-prover
interactive proofs into an entanglement
which is joint work with silver
Caribbean at parabon University
the central theme underlying this talk
is a Quantum analog of NP space which is
space-bounded quantum computation we
studied the complexity class qcms base
where space bounded Quantum verifier is
given access to an exponentially long
classical proof classically this relates
to Savage's theorem showing p-space
equals NP space
we use the concept of streaming proofs
to avoid exponentially white circuits
for long proofs note in Quantum we work
with the proof view of NP space as
opposed to The non-deterministic View
we show how to reduce streaming proofs
to qm A2 and how to Traverse the ground
space of a hamiltonian with local
unitaries
let's start with the introduction
everybody knows the open problem of P
versus NP
the space bounded analog
pspace versus P space however is solved
Savages theorem proves the equality
npspace can be viewed as a piece based
machine with access to an exponentially
long stream proof
as on the figure
the p-space verifier has polynomial
space but exponential runtime
in NP space it gets access to a proof
the proof is streamed so the very first
sees only one pass of the proof
now let's look at the quantum world
where various Notions of space burning
computation have been studied
Waters shows bqp space equals P space
which is a space bounded analog of B
cupp I.E there is no proof
heaven and REM scrim show qma space
equals P space which is like Q may but
with the bqp space verifier receiving a
polynomial sized Quantum proof
however one might argue that the quantum
analog of NP space also needs an
exponential length proof
this leads us to introduce the notion of
qcms Base which is a bqp space verifier
with an exponentially long stream proof
a defined proof steering later more
formally
next I'd like to present our results
first qcma space is equal to next and
therefore Savage's theorem has no
Quantum analog
require and contrast Q's qma space is
equal to P space where qms space only
receives a polycized Quantum proof as
opposed to qcma space which has an
exponentially long streamed classical
proof
the proof is a straightforward
application of the PCB theorem and only
requires Quantum computation for
randomness
second is the universal path following
Lemma which allows us to simulate any
Lipschitz continuous path on the unit
hypersphere within one over X error and
using exponentially many two local
Quantum Gates
so the unique feature of this
construction is that the intermediate
state by applying the gate sequence
always stayeth within 1 over X distance
to the actual path
and someone can fool a Quantum error
correcting code with an exponentially
long sequence of local Errors By
following a path between two code words
in the ground space
third is the embedding limit reducing
qcim a space to the separas bus
hamiltonian problem with 1 over X
problem skip note in this problem we
only minimize energy of a separable
States
this allows us to reduce multi-prover
interactive proofs to qma2 with an
inverse exponential promise Gap in the
number of bits and rounds
next I'll elaborate on the universal
path following them
suppose we have a Quantum error
correcting code encoded in the ground
space of a local hamiltonian with code
words PSI 0 and PSI 1. a common
intuition is that local errors take
codewords out of the ground space this
would imply that local errors cannot
change size 0 to 7 without detection
however our University path following
Lemma shows is to be false as we can
follow any path with one over X
Precision with exponentially many local
Gates
note that there always exists a path
through the ground space between
orthogonal ground States
the path following Lemma allows us to
approximate this path with sufficiently
many two local unitaries note in some
intermediate States we may lie outside
the ground Space by 1 over X
it is well known that there always
exists a local circuit U mapping zero
troops I want
however the previously known
decompositions use large rotations like
x y z or C naught that can take
intermediate States far outside the
ground space
for example if we want to map from zero
zero zero to one one one inside the span
of these states with two local Gates
and apply xxi the intermediate state
is orthogonal to the ground space
more formally let F be ellipset's
continuous path on the unit hypersphere
then there exists for all Epsilon
greater than zero a sequence of M
exponential in epsilon and n two local
unitaries such as all intermediate
States when applying the gate sequence
to the initial state
are Epsilon clause
2f
the idea is now to decompose F into
Epsilon length sub-segments PSI I to psi
Plus 1.
then the rotation between PSI I and PSI
plus 1 can be written as W equals e to
the i h where H has spectral Norm of
Atmos to Epsilon
the next Lemma allows us to decompose
such small rotations approximately into
exponentially many two local Gates
such that we can bound the sum of
distances from identity of gates by
Epsilon to the 1 over 2N
the Epsilon square error allows us to
repeat the decomposition 1 over Epsilon
time with smaller cumulative error
the maximum distance of intermediate
States from PSI I to and PSI I plus 1 is
bounded in terms of Epsilon albeit
exponentially
We Begin the proof by writing H in poly
bases
each term PJ is a tensor product of one
local i x y or Z operators
we can bound the total spectral Norm in
the norm of H which is Epsilon
the Suzuki decomposition allows us to
then decompose you into a product of the
form e to the IP where p is a poly
product
can then decompose these terms into two
local unitaries with the following Lemma
let H be a poly hamiltonian and T is
small pulse time
when e to the I a th can be written
exactly as a product of N squared
terms e to the I
th
with two local police h j and the total
pulse sum of Atmos t to the 1 over 2N
so the pulse time of the decomposition
is bounded in terms of T albeit
exponentially longer
to prove this result we use Lemma of
Clinton Bausch and Cubit year H is 1
over
2i times the commutator of H1 and H2
where H1 and H2 anti-commute and square
to Identity
then you can be decomposed like this
the resulting pulse time is bounded by
the square root of 2 t
we apply this decomposition recursively
let H be a powerly hamiltonian again
we split at qubit J
assuming PJ equals that here
then we can decompose H into H1 and H2
satisfying the conditions of the Lemma
observe that H1 and H2 only interact
non-trivially at qubit J
where we use a well-known property of
the poly operators
note
each step roughly halves the number of
non-identity probably terms but it
increases the pulse time from T to
square root t
the recursive decomposition is
a circuit then looks like this we have
H1 here and here
the H2 here and here
next I will briefly Define the local
hamiltonian problem
we are given a k Local hamiltonian H and
N qubits H can be written as the sum of
local terms terms h i Each of which are
emissions of size 2 to the K times 2 to
the K and only act on a subset of K
qubits we are also given thresholds
Alpha and beta with at least an inverse
polynomial Gap
the problem is not to decide whether the
smallest eigenvalue of H is less than
alpha or greater than beta this is a
promise problem so if Lambda mean is
between Alpha and beta the instance is
invalid
we call Lambda mean the ground state
energy and the corresponding eigenvector
of the ground state
the K local hamiltonian problem is the
canonical complete problem for qma
yes the qma circuit which is like an MA
circuit with a Quantum verify and
Quantum proof
If instead we allow a sparse hamiltonian
instead of local and optimize our
separable states the problem becomes
qma2 complete
qmi 2 is like qma but the verifier
receives two unentangled proofs
we now apply the path following nemma to
the ground state connectivity problem
due to Caribbean and sikora this is the
Quantum analog of classical
reconfiguration problems
we are given a k local hamiltonian age
State Supply and Phi of energy ETA and
numbers M and Epsilon
in the yes case there exists a sequence
of M2 local unitaries mapping PSI to
approximately Phi such that intermediate
states have energy at most ETA plus
Epsilon
in the no case any sequence of length M
mapping side to Phi must have energy at
least ETA plus 2 Epsilon
they show G is Con is qcma complete for
two local gates with polynomial lengths
and error
it is p-space complete for one local
gate in exponential length
you show that if the sequence length is
exponential and the error is
sub-exponential then geoscon has no
known instances for large n
and is therefore trivial this follows by
using the universal path following Lemma
to map from side to file through low
energy space
we can observe a threshold between
sub-exponential error where geoscon
becomes trivial and exponential error
where gscon becomes P space hard
one may ask whether a large M Oil
surgery realizes the one local case
we showed this not to be the case as
geoscon with unbounded M and L equals 1
is still p-space complete
next I present the embedding Lemma
allowing us to embed streaming proofs
into an entanglement
before that we review the Feynman guitar
of circuit hamiltonian Construction
the idea is to reduce qma to the K local
hamiltonian Problem by constructing a
hamiltonian age whose ground state and
Cones the application of the verifiers
gates
this ground state is called the history
States
scientist
test register a for the instillers E
B for the proof and C
for the time step
the history State then contains all time
steps of the computation in uniform
superposition
we Define the hamiltonian H whose ground
state shall be the history state with an
accepting proof
the input hamiltonian H in
forces the ancillas to be zero at time
step 0.
the output term is out
penalizes a rejecting computation
at the last time step
the propagation hamiltonian
Edge prop ensures that the gate VT is
applied from Step T minus 1
to step t
the first two terms of HT model the
transition
and the last makes HT a projector
yeah VT let's apply it from T minus 1 to
T and BT inverse supplied from T to T
minus 1 so backwards
this hamiltonian can easily be made five
local and has ground state psychist for
an accepting PSI
next we'll Define the notion of
streaming proofs
one may ask how can we stream a proof to
a Quantum circuit
for that we implement this circuit here
it has three registers
input
and seller and proof
and it operates in phases
the computation phase that applies
unitaries without
touching the proof register
in the proof phase it sets proof
register with gate WI
by applying X if necessary
the proof bit is then copied to incilla
space
but how do we embed streaming proofs
into the history State Construction
the idea is to move the proof out of the
register and into the superposition over
time steps
therefore we Define the history state
with NCL a proof bit B and time step C
similar to before just that we don't
have a separate proof input here
we can divide the gates into
proof Gates and computation Gates proof
Gates correspond to the Wi from the
previous slide and are not now on our
priori and depend on the proof why
therefore we write it here
so in a way the proof is now encoded
implicitly in the time steps
the challenge now is that the
propagation hamiltonian needs to know
oil gates in advance
a token the history State encode the
future
what if we allow two parallel worlds a
more formally a separable hamiltonian
Both Worlds can choose whether to apply
I or X at each time step
we Define the flag schedule to enforce
that both worlds apply the same gate
it consists of h t i times htx
plus htx times HTI
which is the transition hamiltonian
forget X
or I respectively
therefore we don't fix the gate a priori
but this gadget simulates the Boolean
equality function because if for example
the first world applies an X and the
second an I then the first term would be
violated
the low energy state is now supposed to
be the tensor product of two history
States for an optimal proof y star
but this is unsound as states of this
from here
are in the ground space as both htx and
h t i i annihilated by the plus State
since it is invariant and are both X and
I
the fix is to use i x instead of X which
is a non-trivial insight
we can now Define the complete
hamiltonian from the flux Gadget
again we have H in h prop and H out
but now they are left and right terms
in Edge prop the flux Gadget is only
applied to proof Gates
but this is still unsound with flux
gadgets on multiple time steps
suppose the left term has only weight on
the last time step
and R and the right only on the first
half step
then L annihilates all time steps but m
and R all but zero
the fix is to enforce Symmetry by using
the projector under the symmetric
Subspace
then if H Sim times PSI L tends up say R
is 0 psi L and percent R must be equal
further note that H Sim is not local but
only sparse
now let's analyze parts of the black
sketches unfortunately we don't have
time to go in depth here
so if we set the left register to say
one then we can show that any low energy
set on R must implement the unit Terry U
parameterized in a t and BT which is the
normalization of the term 80 times IX
plus BT times I
we can diagonalize the residual
propagation term on the r system which
is obtained by applying PSI 1 to the
left hamiltonians
here we have the residual propagation
term again
and S and kitab's proof we conjugate by
the unitary w
and we obtain a tri-diagonal matrix
note that we get
a i and equals 0 and bi equals 1 or vice
versa if the proofer is honest then W
has -1 on the off diagonal and two on
the diagonal just like in kitab's proof
finally
we State the embedding Lemma
consider a Quantum verify Q with M local
Gates and classical stream proof of
length 2 to the p
q and sellers and a threshold gap of 2
to the minus r
then we can reduce Q to a separate
response hamiltonian instance h on o of
Q Plus log M qubits with a gap of Omega
of 1 over 2 to the r times m
as a corollary we can reduce qcms space
with proof length p and Q and Silas to
the separate's passive electronian
problem with a gap exponential and
approved length
we can also reduce MIP with p proofers r
rounds u-space and T bits of
communication per round to SSH on all of
U qubits with a promise gap of Omega to
the 2 to the minus t r times p
the proof uses the standard trick of
sending the concatenation of all
interactions between prover and verifier
as proof to a qcma space verifier
lastly we show that a particular version
of gscon is next complete namely with
the sparse hamiltonian 1 over X promise
Gap X many two local Gates that are
required to not interact across a given
by partition of the cubits with the
consequence the intermediate states are
separable
we conclude the talk with open problems
gscon with exponential length and 1 over
x x Gap lies somewhere between P space
and next can we improve these bounds
can the embedding Lemma be extended to
allow for more gauge choices
so not only I and X currently our proof
requires the structure resulting from
using I and I X
the embedding Lemma recovers the result
of blear and tap but NP has a lock size
qma2 proof with one over polygap can
this be improved to a constant Gap
thank you for listening feel free to
send me any questions you may have